Çeviri: Sessenol Projesi
Gözden geçirme: Meric Aydonat
Nasıl diyeyim?
Benim adım Nuran Erden.
Germiyan’dan geliyorum.
Benim maceram;
sandalyeleri boyamakla,
tabela boyamakla başladı.
Ondan sonra duvarlara başladık biraz.
Arkasından yok benim duvar
yok senin duvar derken
İşte bu yavaş şeye de uyuyor bizim biraz;
yavaş yaşamaya, yavaş şehirlere...
Zaten Türkiye’nin
ilk slowfood köyüyüz biz.
Ama çok da yavaş gidiyoruz,
herhalde beş senede anca gelişeceğiz
(Gülüşmeler ve alkışlar)
Ondan sonra tabelaları boyadık.
Tabelalardan sandalye boyayacağız dedik.
Sandalyeleri ben biraz özgün olsun, bize
özel olsun, diye sandalye boyadım.
Arkadaşlarım dedi ‘’İyi, güzel oldu.’’
Küçücük bir duvar vardı,
biraz oraya denedim.
O da güzel oldu.
Ondan sonra dedik;
bir tek mavimiz var,
maviyle boyuyoruz.
Mavi-beyaz maceramız böyle başladı.
Maviyle boyadık bir duvarı
ama bir başladım birazcık
bir karanfil, bir lale...
Ondan sonra, o karanfilden laleden sonra
annem -rahmetli- rahatsızlandı.
Hastaneye gittik.
2 ay 3 ay durdu o.
Bizim yavaşlık hepten varmış demek.
Ondan sonra onu tamamladım.
Bir de bizim köyümüz
transit geçişin yapıldığı;
sahilde sitelerin olduğu,
yazlıkların olduğu bir yer.
Ekranda gördüğünüz gibi,
işte ‘Germiyan Hatırası’.
Ben onu iki ayda falan tamamladım.
Normalde yapsam iki saatlik iş.
(Gülüşmeler)
O şey; bizim köyden
geçiyor insanlar ama
hiç etrafına bakmıyorlar.
Hiç merak yok insanlarda.
30-35 yıldır köyden geçen insanlar var.
Anam insan merak eder ya!
Ben olsam orda 35 yıl geçsem o köyden
çoğunluğuyla akraba olurum.
Hiç merak yok.
Dedim: ’’Dur ben sizi köye sokacağım.’’
O duvar da boş.
Orası biraz tuzak olarak
o Germiyan Hatırasını yaptım.
İnsanlar birer ikişer başladılar girmeye.
Resim çekiyorlar.
Köydeki insanlara dedim ki:
‘’Bak, bu resimlere
çok insanlar gelecek.’’
Ama tabi kimse inanmıyor.
Bir de insanlar görmediği şeyi
hayal edemiyorlar.
Ondan sonra ne gelir ne olur ne yaşanır?
Onlar yok insanlarda.
Ha oradaki insanları
küçümsemek için söylemiyorum.
Ben de olsam ben de aynı şeyi yapacağım.
Ondan sonra gel zaman, git zaman
üstünde Germiyan Hatırası yazıyor.
Bana dediler ki;
yaşlılar ve elli yaşın üzerindekiler
sokakta oturuyorlar yaz günü
Şey dediler;
‘’İyi hoş resmi anladık da yazıyı
niye yazıyorsun?’’
‘’Be insanlar! dedim.
Tamam bu söz uçar yazı kalır.
Bu resmi çektirecek insanlar
ama burası neresi?
Birçok kişi bilmiyor ki adını.
Köyden geçiyoruz, ne köyü?
Çok yerleşikler biliyor
ama diğerleri bilmiyor.
Ondan sonra üstüne
"Germiyan Hatırası" yazdık.
Onun da esin kaynağı,
eski Türk filmlerinde
‘İstanbul Hatırası’ vardı ya;
bulsam hala gidip çekineceğim
içimde kalmıştır.
O yüzden ‘Germiyan Hatırası’ yazdım.
Birçoğu da dedi ki:
‘’R’sini ters yaz.’’
Ya, dedim.
Herkes olur, ben niye yazayım?
R’sini ters yazacağıma
R’sini yere düşürürüm ben onun.
Ondan sonra küçücük
yan tarafına şey yazdım:
Nuran Erden yazdım.
Millet dövecekti beni neredeyse.
Niye adımı yazıyormuşum?
Dedim: ‘’Tamam da bunu ben
yapıyorum, ben yazacağım adımı."
Sen mi yazacaksın?
Ben yazacağım.
(Gülüşmeler ve alkışlar)
Ondan sonra 2016;
bir komşu, hatta öğrencim,
ben üç yıl da halk eğitimde
nakış hocalığı yaptım.
Ben sana biraz renk vereyim, dedi.
Yaptım da ben profesyonel değilim.
Anlamıyorum resimden de işte ben
resim de demiyorum onlara.
Herkes ressam diyor
ama ben ressam değilim.
Ressamlara hakaret olmasın.
Ben diyorum ki, iki çizdirik atıyorum.
Ondan sonra başladık.
Küçücük güller vardı.
Deneyeyim bakalım, renk nasıl olacak?
İnsanlar da böyle renkli şeyleri daha çok
seviyor, daha mutluluk veriyor.
Şöyle kırmızı güller yaptım küçücük.
Bana da aşk geldi.
dedim bu olacak.
Ondan sonra başladık renkleştirmeye.
Ondan sonra başladı insanlar:
‘’Ay bende de renk vardı,
getireyim sana.’’
İyi, getirin bana.
Ondan sonra başladık renklendirmeye.
Şey oldu;
bizim Germiyan Festivalimiz var.
Ama Ekmek Festivali değil,
Germiyan Festivali.
Herkes Ekmek Festivali diyor.
Germiyan Festivalimiz var.
Oraya şey yapacağım;
duvarların birçoğunu yaptım
ama bir tane bayan kuş yapmıştım.
Yalnız kaldı.
Onun yanına bir tane
baykuş yapacağım.
Sipariş geliyor.
Diyorlar ki: ‘’Baykuşun yanına
çocuklarını da yap.
Yuvasını yap, yavrularını yap.’’
Ya, dedim insanlar,
Biraz bakmayı öğrenin.
Doğada yaşıyoruz.
Baykuşun yavrusunu
hiç kimse yanında görmez.
Çünkü baykuş yavrusuyla gezmez.
Onların diğer kuşlar gibi,
sepet gibi bir yuvası da olmaz.
Onların yaşadıkları yer neresi?
Harabeler, direk tepeleri,
yıkık dökük yerler.
Ondan sonra gördüğünüz
şu bayan kuşları yaptım.
Orada bir detay var.
Bay kuş bayan kuşa ne yapıyor?
Çiçek veriyor.
Benim babam anneme
iki günde bir çiçek getirir.
‘’Hanım, karısını seven adam
karısına çiçek getirir.’’
derdi.
Siz yapıyor musunuz?
(Alkışlar)
İşte bu bayan kuş
ve bay kuşlarımız onları;
baykuş bilgeliği anlatıyor,
bende bunu sonradan öğrendim.
Bize dövletti denir ona.
Devlet gücü simgelediği için
dövletti denir.
insanları da biraz ürperten bir kuştur.
Gözleri kocaman olduğu için
ama biz onları sevimli hale getirdik.
Şimdi herkes seviyor
baykuşları zannedersem.
Altına da nar yaptım.
Nar da neyi simgeler?
Bereketi, bolluğu.
Bizim köyde zaten her bahçede nar vardır.
Şu resim sosyal medyada paylaşıldı.
Bende akıllı telefon da yok bilmiyorum.
Aslı Albayrak paylaştı bunu.
-Çeşme Belediyesi çalışanı,
halkla ilişkiler müdürü-
Ondan sonra bir gecede bin kişi,
ardından beş bin kişi,
sonra Cezmi Kaloriferde yayınlanıyor
seksen altı bin kişi bir kerede
(Alkışlar)
Onlar yayınlamasaydı,
ondan sonra 3 Ekim bir baktım;
HaberTürk’ü, CNN’i, arkasından
Doğan Haber Ajans’ı,
İhlas Haber Ajans’ı…
Akşama Anadolu Ajansı arıyor:
‘’Abla gelip çeksek.’’
Günaydın, dedim.
Herkes çekti, gitti senin aklın nerede?
(Gülüşmeler ve alkışlar)
Bizim macera bu şekilde başladı,
bu şekilde gidiyor inşallah.
Ve benim hayatta en çok
istediğim şeyin başında şu vardı;
benim köyüm öyle bir yerde ki
ne İzmir/Çeşme yolunun kenarında
ne sahilin kenarında, saklı bir yer.
Adı yok.
Sonra bir de şu var;
beni en çok yaralayan, üzen bir şey.
İzmir Büyükşehir Belediyesi'nin
hazırladığı bir yürüyüş yolları
artı bir bisiklet yolları var:
Efes-Mimas yolu.
Bizim köye getirdiler
tabelaları taktılar, bilmem ne yaptılar.
Artı köyün muhtarlığında şey var:
Nasıl diyeyim size?
Çeşme haritası var.
Biz orada 5-6 yüz yıllık
bir yörük köyüyüz.
Türk köyüyüz ama adımız yok.
Benim nüfusumda Germiyan yazıyor.
Ama ne bileyim, tapularda
Germiyan yazıyor,
Germiyan diye geçiyoruz,
herkes Germiyanlı diye biliyor
ama adımız yok.
Nasıl kadının adı yok.
Germiyan’ın da adı yok.
Ondan sonra bu çok içime işlemiştir.
Bu arada ben Trakya Üniversitesi
Kırklareli Meslek Yüksek Okulu
halıcılıkdan mezunum.
Orada falan veya
başka yerde ‘’Nerelisin?’’
‘’Germiyanlıyım.’’
Germiyan neresi, herkes bilmiyor ki.
Germiyan deyince, neresi: Çeşme.
Çeşme İzmir’e bağlı, zaten popüler
bir yer herkes biliyor.
Şimdi artık inanıyorum ki,
Germiyan deyince haritalarda çıkacak.
Benim istediğim,
benim nakşetmek istediğim,
benim anlatmak istediğim,
benim köyümün tanınmasıydı.
Kesinlikle ben şöhret olayım, bir şeyler
olayım diye hiç uğraşmadım.
Ya zaten bir şey seni bulacaksa buluyor.
Bu şeyler de beni kendisi geldi buldu.
(Gülüşmeler)
Yani bir sürü ulusal basına çıktık.
Ben bilmiyordum bu kadar çıkacağımızı.
Şimdi mesela orada geliyor,
diyelim bir sürü kanallar geldi.
TRT Word’ünden tut TRT Avaz’a kadar
çıkmadığımız televizyon kalmadı.
Orada kolay.
Belki milyonlara konuşacağız ama
bir kameraman bir şey var.
Burada çok insan olunca
insan biraz ürküyor.
Ben bir de şuna inanan insanlardanım:
Herkesin, yani bu projem
kafamda olan bir şey
orada bir köy var uzakta,
o köy bizim köyümüzdür
diye öğretirlerdi ya bize ilkokulda.
Onun için ben diyorum ki,
herkesin bir köyü olsun.
Herkes köyüne dönsün.
Atanızın, babanızın, dedenizin, annenizin
yoktur belki, babanızın yoktur.
Büyük şehirlerdekilerin çoğunun yoktur.
Mutlaka dedenizin ya da
büyük dedenizin vardır bir köyü.
Herkes köyüne sahip çıksın istiyorum.
Benim aşkım, benim tutkum,
benim en çok sevdiğim
şeyim benim köyüm.
Gerçekten benim için
Germiyan demek, tutku demek.
Hani herkesin bir aşkı vardır ya,
benim de aşkım Germiyan.
Seviyorum ve şuna inanan insanlardanım:
İnsanın toprağı o insanın özgürlüğüdür.
Bana göre Germiyan
benim toprağım ve özgürlüğüm.
Ha bu tanıtmalarla
bir şeyler yaptık ettik.
Biraz kötü de mi yaptık bilmiyorum.
Şimdi herkes tapu elinde;
benim malım satılsın,
benim malım satılsına girdiler.
Kötü ettik biraz galiba çok tanıtmakla.
Ama diyorum ki; hepimiz
köylerimize sahip çıkalım.
Hepimiz köylerimizi sevelim.
Hepimiz köylerimize dönelim.
Çünkü bizim özümüz o.
Onun yanında hani
köye dönmek değil bu.
Demek istediğim, Slowfood’un
felsefesinde de olan
bizim özümüzde de olan,
hepimiz özümüze dönelim.
Ne bileyim, gerçek bir domates yiyelim.
Ne bileyim susuz da yetişir.
Ben bugün Bursa’yı gezerken
baktım ve abime dedim ki:
’’Millet burada hakikaten
sulak toprakların insanı,
herkes iri yarı biz çok küçük kaldık.’’
(Gülüşmeler)
Yani biz kıraç yerin insanıyız,
bizde toprak çok yok.
Bizde zeytinyağı var, zeytin var.
Susuz yetişen domates var,
susuz yetişen bamya var.
Ne bileyim, biz işte biraz
kıraç yer insanıyız.
Yani hepimiz, ben kıraç yer insanı
olduğum için utanmıyorum,
şey yapmıyorum, onu demek istemiyorum
Hepimiz toprağımıza sahip çıkalım.
Toprağımız bizim özgürlüğümüz.
Nasıl evimize gidince ne diyoruz?
En güzel yeri de gezsek,
en güzel yerde de otursak
ne diyoruz evimize gidince:
Oh be evim, oh!
Çirkin de olsa, yamuk da olsa,
yılık da olsa bizim evimiz.
Aynı şekilde ben de diyorum ki
hepimiz köyümüze, vatanımıza,
toprağımıza sahip çıkalım.
Özgürlüğümüze sahip çıkalım.
İnsanlar özgürlüğünü yitirdiği sürece;
onu da yap, bunu da yap,
şunu da yap demeye başlıyorlar.
Bana birçok kişi diyor ki:
’’ Bana şunu çiz.’’
Yok kardeşim öyle ısmarlama iş yok.
Ben duvarın başına geçtim,
ne hissettim onu çizerim.
(Alkışlar)
Daha sonra mesela bir de
şöyle bir şeyler oldu:
Önceleri yadırgayanlar
ne olacak bunlar ya?
Kimisi diyordu ki:
Bulamaç yapıyorsun köyü yapma,
güzel kalsın, boş ver!’’
Şimdi birinci şartımız:
köyde duvarına resim isteyen herkes
önce badanasını yapacak.
En azından bir hijyen geliyor mu?
Geliyor.
Sonra duvarlar temizleniyor.
Sonra diyorlar ki:’ ’Ahmet’in evini
daha güzel yaptın da,
Mehmet’inki güzel olmadı
ona çok mu özen gösteriyorsun?
Onu daha mı çok seviyorsun?’’
yok öyle bir şey.
Benim için herkes aynı.
Bazıları da dedi ki:
"Ben duvarıma resim yapmanı istemiyorum.’’
Dedim kardeşim, evin içi senin
sokak neresi oluyor
kamuya ait.
Sokak kamuya geçti mi sokak benim.
(Alkışlar ve gülüşmeler)
Birisi dedi ki, ben çizmeni istemiyorum.
Öyle mi dedin sen?
Ben bir başladım duvara,
baştan sona kadar.
Ve böyle tam sürat
mübalağasız 7-8 metrelik yeri
bir buçuk saatte boyadım geçtim.
Ne olur olmaz,belki boyatmaz bana.
Sonra ne bileyim mesela ben,
bu kadar yerlere gelip konuşacağımı,
veya bu kadar insanın ilgi göstereceğini,
tahmin etmiyordum.
Yalnız köyün tanınacağını
çok tahmin ediyordum.
Bu resimlerin ilgi çekeceğini
tahmin ediyordum.
Belki arkaya giremeyeceğim yerlerde
şimdi portakalların içine girebildim.
İnsanların, ben her zaman
inandığım şeydir
insanlara değer vereceksin,
yaşadığın yere değer vereceksin,
yaşadığın ülkeye değer vereceksin,
insanları seveceksin.
Bizim oraya geliyorlar ve diyorlar ki:
"Bak şu eski binalar çok güzel.’’
Her şeye ruhunu katacaksın, ruhunu.
Ruhunu katmazsan olmuyor.
O evleri yapan insanlar tamam.
Mesela bizim evin adı ‘’Koca Emine’’.
Onu neden koydun diyorlar?
Benim babaannem kendine ait
neyi var neyi yoksa satmış,
sadece babama ev yapmış.
Eskiden böyle kira mı varmış?
Köy yerinde kira zaten olmaz.
Bir şey yapacak.
Her şeyini satıyor ve
sadece o evi yapıyor.
Ben babaanneme olan saygımdan,
onun emeğine olan saygımdan
o evin adını mesela
‘’Koca Emine’’ koydum.
Herkes diyor;
Daha sonra bana diyorlar ki:
’’Koca Emine nasılsın?’’
İyiyim diyorum
yapacak bir şey yok.
Yani insanın özünü sevmesi,
toprağını sevmesi,
kendi kültürüne sahip çıkması
bence her şeyden önemli.
Vallahi kim ne derse desin;
bize, bizden başka dost
olduğuna inanmıyorum.
Önce kendimizi seveceğiz,
ülkemizi seveceğiz,
bayrağımızı seveceğiz.
Buna inanıyorum.
Sağ olun.
(Alkışlar)